mais qu en planète koei games redonner
sa grandeur à notre planète pendant sa
campagne présidentielle emmanuel macron
multiplie les discours vibrant en faveur
de l'environnement
ce positionnement lui vaudra même d'être
consacré champion de la terre par l'onu
ou 2018
champion des discours peut-être pour les
actions c'est moins sûr en réalité le
champion du climat semble rencontrer
quelques difficultés à respecter tous
ses engagements en matière d'écologie
depuis presque cinq ans et la tenue de
la cap 21 au bourget la france n'a
jamais réussi à tenir ses objectifs de
réduction des émissions de gaz à effet
de serre pour éviter d'autres loupé le
gouvernement a décidé début 2000 vingt
ans de revoir ses ambitions à la baisse
et les émissions de co2 à la hausse en
2010 est emmanuel macron avait promis de
faire de la santé environnementale une
priorité de son quinquennat
l'interdiction du glyphosate herbicide
connu pour ses liens probables avec le
cancer et c'est dommage sur
l'environnement était alors la
principale promesse en la matière j'ai
demandé au gouvernement de prendre les
dispositions nécessaires pour que
l'utilisation du glyphosate soit
interdite en france
dès que des alternatives auront été
trouvés deux ans plus tard le chef de
l'état revenait sur sa promesse est ce
qu'on peut dire y aura plus du tout de
glyphosate dans trois ans impossible je
vais pas vous mentir c'est pas vrai une
autre promesse environnementale qui
emmanuel macron n'a pas tenu sortir des
énergies fossiles fermeture des
centrales à charbon fin des permis
d'hydrocarbures classement de 30% de nos
espaces maritimes et terrestres en aires
protégées
nous n'avons pas attendu pour déployer
un agenda écologique entre priorités
économiques et agendas écologique la
balance semble plus souvent pesé en
faveur du premier
en réalité elle est centrale n'ont pas
de sou tout était fermé
pour exemple l'état à prolonger
l'exploitation de la centrale de
cordemais jusqu'à 2026 alors que toutes
les installations similaires devaient
fermer en 2022
devant la convention citoyenne pour le
climat créé à la suite du grand débat
national en réponse au mouvement
des gilets jaunes emmanuel macron
s'était engagé à ce que les propositions
soient mises en oeuvre au plus vite
j'irai au bout de ce contrat moral qui
nous lie plusieurs mois après cette
convention force est de constater un
détricotage total des propositions
émises par les citoyens parmi les
propositions qui ont fait l'objet d'un
être rétro pédalage citons par exemple
la demande d'un moratoire sur la 5g
elle a été balayée par le président la
france va prendre le tournant de la 5g
parce que c'est le tournant de
l'innovation et j'entends beaucoup de
voix qui s'élèvent pour nous expliquer
qu'il faudrait relever la complexité des
problèmes contemporains en revenant à la
lampe à huile
je ne crois pas au modèle un mish
dernière mesure controversée est la
réintroduction des néonicotinoïdes tueur
d'abeilles qui devait définitivement
être interdite en juillet 2020 c'est
puissant pesticide pourront être à
nouveau utilisé jusqu'au 1er juillet
le décalage entre les discours et les
actes d' emmanuel macron sur l'écologie
est abyssal pendant ce temps le
dérèglement climatique s'accélère
cette année nous avons connu le mois de
septembre le plus chaud jamais
enregistré
mais il reste encore 18 mois au chef de
l'état pour rallier les paroles aux
actes et peut-être redonner un peu de sa
grandeur à notre planète